Wait, I gotta move some stuff around.
Oh, it's one of those types.
Oh, wait.
One.
Wait, one.
I was too busy getting my water.
KC Ropter!
May 15th.
What's your birthday?
That was two days ago.
I've gone to a con over the weekend and met Josh, Keaton and
Paul Eiding I also ensured you were with me in spirit by
wearing my Mito shirt Now I watch Mito, great birthday
weekend Happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, can I do something real quick?
Hold on.
Oh, oh!
One second.
We're okay.
I think.
My hand.
We're okay.
Maybe.
Today might be a little scoffed.
She fell down a well.
Oh, chat is broken.
Thank you.
That's so funny.
It didn't break yesterday.
And it broke today.
How curious.
How curious indeed.
I've been a third.
3d 3 today i just felt like it i just felt like it i was
like i'm gonna be in 3d
one more dimension one more dimension one more dimension
yeah i think that oh wow thank you table dome Thank you so
much!
Thank you for the...
The pink O'Donnell.
I'm celebrating my birthday with my family!
Happy birthday!
I'll have to catch the vibe, help you feel better soon.
Sorry if I sound so nicely.
I'm still sick.
I'm sick today.
Today's still?
When 40?
What do you want to smell me?
I've given my perfume already.
What else is in 40?
Uh...
What else is in 4D?
They're calling her a triple threat.
Two ear!
Two ear infections!
What sinus infection?
Nobody else could ever do it.
Thank you, Skeleton, thank you.
Spy Kids 4D.
Is this loud?
Turn it down a little bit.
Shrek is in 4D.
Oh my gosh!
My...
My plane had like every shrek you could imagine i should
have watched some more i have another flight coming up so
i'm gonna watch some more shrek but they even had like the
haunting of far quad i've never even heard of that before
they had that they had uh far uh far the never the idol the
i just i can't remember I can't remember.
I hope you feel better soon, Minto.
Thank you, Brandon!
Thank you.
I bet they did not have 4D in each track, so...
Hmm.
You can experience 4D, Minto, if you spray something
mint-scented in your room.
She's the sickest to ever do it.
So sick.
Sick.
She's so sick.
Same.
sick sick same time as Nimi suspicious were you kissing no
no no but she looks so cute in a new outfit doesn't she go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go
playing Subnautica 2!
For those who I saw some people asking if I've played the
first Subnautica and I did a teeny tiny tiny bit but oh my
gosh I had an absolute fever dream of an experience maybe
like a year two years ago or something where where I did
nothing I was literally like I just became like a a ball
of...
Hold on, sorry, I'm trying to adjust stuff still on my
computer.
I was like a ball of spiritual nothingness because I was
feeling...
My spiritual energy was way too low.
And so I spent the whole week binging someone playing
Subnautica.
So I experienced all of Subnautica through a streamer.
Ah well, thank you so much for the tangenta, thank you!
Yeah, become ball.
I looked like you guys.
I looked like a little I-boo.
Probably not as cute, though.
No, no way as cute.
She's just like me for real, for real.
After yesterday's stream, I downloaded P-Cross S9 and got
hooked and played for four hours.
Thank you, and damn you, Minky.
more like peak cross it's it's too good wait why is my other
hand not working hold on I'm setting things up hello hand
there we go peak peak cross it's peak it is peak peak peak
rush today besides being a sickie Vivi Kourt thank you so
much for the...
Bye, good to thank you.
I...
I have been...
Oh my gosh, I have been looking at new maize cafes.
My...
My move is imminent.
Ah!
I'm scared.
Underwater stuff in video games gives me a heebie-jeebies.
I'm gonna play it.
Pay attention to 3D Minto.
I will be here to take away your...
Actually, I'm a ghost.
I should be giving you more heebies than jeebies.
Oh, gosh, I'm a new robot.
Thank you so much for the opportunity to get in.
Thank you.
Thanks for the reminder to do my Meow Tower dailies, of
course.
I watched a streamer with a Thassusophobia play the first
one.
It was fun.
Not a Thassusophobia.
the deep ocean is far more terrifying than Minto what no I'm
a ghost I'm literally I'm I died to scare I was dead I was I
was dead I was died it I was I was I was death to scare the
sassy phobia you afraid of a little saiyas
Wait a second, one second, two.
Maybe this will help.
I'm gonna get you.
Hands up.
Don't tickle me.
I think tickling is a form of torture.
So...
I could tickle you.
Play the sonic drowning music to activate childhood trauma
with video game water.
Never catch you live.
Good morning, Mito.
Good morning.
Don't do... Raise your hand if you agree that tickling is a
sign of... of torture.
Raise your hand.
If you think that tickling is a form of torture, not a sign.
Look at my pinky.
Like, it's just kind of...
sticks out like that I told you guys I have fancy hands for
some reason my pinky sticks out good everybody agrees I
don't know how long today's stream will be because I am
sicky it's struggling watching me hold my water bottle it
It looked like I just poured my water all over me.
Oh, here I am.
Oh, yes.
Oh, delicious hydration all over my face.
Oh, yeah.
So sick.
So fancy.
Yes.
Hey, Minto, I've been watching your MGS4 playthrough while
working this week.
Thanks for getting me through a busy week.
Thank you, Jambo, for watching it.
Thank you.
I hope you're enjoying my...
Oh gosh, oh my gosh, I was having like a real moment
yesterday.
I was, I think I saw like, it was either, I think it was
like either, I don't know, I don't remember where I saw it.
It might have been like a Reddit thread or something that
was like, when you see, oh I think it was Reddit.
I was like, when you see a PlayStation, what?
do you what game comes to your brain first and like people
were posting metal gear and i was just like i didn't even
play metal gear when it came out but i was like thinking i
was just like man it's been a while now since i've played
metal gear for the first time kingdom heart is a ps2
ps2 but i was just thinking like man I was feeling so
nostalgic for the first time I played Metal Gear.
Because I think the first time I played Metal Gear also was
like a really...
To me, at the time, it was a really big, like, turning point
of my career.
My brain turned into mush after that.
What's up, PS2?
Shut up!
So I was like, man, I was feeling so nostalgic for like just
the pictures people were posting.
I was like, it's so strange.
Super retro.
Is it?
TSS Master, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
I've been trying to get a teal ghost bobo in Bo Bo Bay.
What is a bobo?
What is it?
When I finally get a...
Should I name it Minto or Aibu?
Ah!
Aibu because I am Minto.
I'm not Teal, I am Mint.
It is in the name.
I am Mint.
Just finished watching the Wolf Among Us playthrough.
It was fun.
Thank you!
I thought you were going to tickle us when we raised our
hand.
Oh, I could have!
I should have.
Paper towel finds.
For what?
Oh, for me dumping my water all over me.
The real 4D experience emptying the water bottle.
But yeah.
Can I lift my arms?
Put your hands in the air.
Don't look.
Okay, I'm not gonna do that again.
way up to the ceiling, thank you.
What if I turn to the side a little?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait.
It looks like I'm blocking the sun.
It's too bright in here.
How rude.
Yeah!
Waku, waku for waki!
What was that?
There's creatures in this sea?
Spooky.
A whale?
I have no t- Oh, that's a lie.
I still have my tissue.
Hack.
Okay.
Oh, Chad died again.
But yeah, sorry if I sound so nasally and sound incoherent,
like I can't make a proper thought.
It's because my brain is...
My brain is...
Just like that.
So, same actually.
Scrambled like an egg.
I'm scrambled.
I'm all scrambled.
I'm all mixed up.
my but I did just take some medicine so I hopefully should
be okay she's already underwater that's me swimming around
wait can I actually
she's swimming she do away doggy paddle but yes so I just
kind of wanted to like dip my toes into Subnautica 2.
I did enjoy Subnautica 1.
So I don't know if I'll do...
I know it's like early access at the moment.
It's not exactly the full game.
So I don't know if I'll do the full game, but it is kind of
like a fun game to just kind of swim around and do.
Toes?
Did that get you excited?
It's roughly 25% of the game.
Bad little?
Wow.
Wowie, wowie.
I wonder if there will be some critters that we remember
from the first game.
I wonder.
And also, there's multiplayer, so I kind of want to do like
a Densetsu collab or something sometime.
Actually, wait, is it only two people?
Or...
Okay, three play.
Can I have all my goals?
Can I have four?
Yippee!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm going to send it to them right now.
I'm going to say, hey.
Actually, it's funny.
I'm like, haven't even played the game.
Do you guys want to play Subnautica 2 with me?
Room for Berry!
It's up to four players.
We could also have Barry.
LaBow.
And I'm going to send nodding.
Actually, wait, wait.
I want to send Minto brebspin.
There we go.
Minto brebspin.
bread spin i'm like a loaf of bread and i'm spinning around
okay i don't think they're away i i don't think they're
available at the moment though impromptu collab i wish but i
think our time zones make it kind of difficult at the moment
actually what are what are they doing oh well vicky will be
streaming later i don't i don't know what phoebe's doing
like a record You spin me right round, baby, like round Like
a minto bread, right round, round VTuber collapse seems so
hard to set up?
No!
I think for me, I'm very...
I'm very shy.
So, for me, I get shy, I get nervous messaging people.
But...
I mean, obviously not Denza, too.
I don't get...
Well, I do get a little shy too, sometimes.
Wasn't VB hanging out with her sister?
Oh, yes, she did say that her sister was graduating.
Yes, yes, yes.
It is that season, isn't it?
Wow.
Graduation time.
Not for VTuber.
For people of education.
No, no, no, graduation.
G-word quiet.
But, um, yeah.
We'll just, we can see about a collab in the future, though.
Cool.
Single player game.
Oh, no health.
Hunger, Thirst, Raw.
Oh, no.
Streaming in 3D while setting up collabs.
My Oshi is a great multitasker.
Thank you.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes.
Praise me more.
Do you ever play the movement games?
Wait, I know there was the movement game that came out
recently for the Switch.
I've been wanting to play it.
But I was like, would anybody watch?
I was like, will anybody watch me play the movement?
games.
Actually, I just recently got a little May bag.
3D Mito today, yay!
Yay!
Hello!
Yeah!
Maybe we could do it this week.
Maybe?
I love movement.
I want to play movement game.
I have been, I have most of my week planned out, but I have
a couple days that I was like, Actually, there's like,
because, I mean, currently working on a couple games that I
have been working on, and, like, you know, I'm in the middle
of, and then...
Sorry if my hands are crazy, by the way.
It's ghostliness.
But also...
Um...
Uh...
What was I saying?
Oh, there were some things I was like, oh, well, maybe if I
want to do something new.
Um, schedule, yeah.
Yeah.
Of course, dummy, we watch you play anything.
Well, I don't know.
Not everybody thinks that way.
Which is okay.
I'm also kind of similar like that, though.
Like, even if I have a favorite streamer, actually, you
know, like, I'm very shocked sometimes that some people will
watch me play everything or anything.
Like, that, I'm so, like, I'm so shocked and honored at the
same time.
Because even for my favorite streamers, if they're playing
something that I'm not super interested in like I might skip
on it you know what I mean but for some people if they watch
everything that I play I'm like oh oh you're too kind both
are valid I agree I agree because your time is valuable so
you should spend it doing what you want to do and what you
want to watch you know what I mean that's what I think I
think you should be like oh If I don't like this, I can
spend my time doing something else, so...
I think that's totally okay.
I don't get mad about it.
But...
I will be a little sad if I don't see you.
I do get a little sad if I don't see you in the chat, so...
You know.
Sometimes I'm unsure if I'll like the game, but you always
make it interesting and fun.
I really appreciate that.
That's why, you know, that's why I try to do like a mix
between games that people might know and games that...
that maybe it's like, oh, what is this?
Yeah, kind of have to watch to see if you'll like it.
Kind of situation.
Get it twisted, she notices me specifically.
Yes, you, you, oh, my fingers.
Oh!
What's that?
Are we okay?
Yeah, we're fine.
My time is valuable which is why I watch every video stream
I can no matter the game.
Thank you.
Regardless of the game, we like you.
So thank you.
I appreciate that very very very much.
fingers.
Stop doing that!
We're breaking free!
Soaring!
When I watched your faith series, I had no idea about the
game.
It was so good!
I can't believe I slept on him back in the day.
Thank you.
I always like that, too.
Always finding, like, a...
Well, I guess Faith is not, like, a hidden gem.
Because it's pretty well known.
But finding hidden gems sometimes is really good.
Oh!
Wait, my finger doing that?
Wait, I have a new WebTune recommendation, you guys.
Hold on.
I've been super into it.
It's like...
I just caught up on it today.
It's...
It's mysterious and spooky and creepy and also like a crime
solving, but also like supernatural at the same time.
Okay, hold on.
Is it digital circus?
No!
Why would I be digital circus?
Okay, I don't speak Korean, so I'm gonna type it.
And then I'm also gonna say it.
Okay.
The...
Maybe it's Gichon Village Mystery.
It's my current recommendation.
So basically it's about this guy who goes back to this
village that his grandma lived at.
And he's a serial killer.
Bum bum.
He's on the run.
But the village is also really suspicious.
They're all sus.
They come in.
like why are you here you're an outsider you need to leave
and he's just like nah my grandma lived here and i'm gonna
stay and they're like they're like you're a well no they
don't say you're a serial killer sorry but they're like you
shouldn't be here you're gonna regret this and some creepy
things happen and there's like ghosts and stuff too but but
it's also it's also like It's like, oops, all serial
killers.
Kind of.
Hmm.
It's my recommendation.
I was like, I kind of binged it the past couple of days.
It was like, it was like such a good mix of mystery and
ghostly spookiness and stuff.
Are there cute ghosts?
No, they're quite creepy.
How many chapters?
Right now, I'm on chapter 80.
And...
Yeah, I'm on chapter 80.
There's quite a lot of chapters.
Mito, since you've been tell-tale-tale-ing, I need to hype
my favorite game by them, Sam and Max.
I think you'd really enjoy it.
It is more humor-focused.
Oh, really?
Sam and Max.
Wait, I'm gonna write it down.
I didn't realize Telltale had so many games.
Like, way many games.
Tell-tale-sam.
And Max, apparently there's even a Jurassic Park one.
Dinosaur?
This is me.
Wait.
This is me as a dinosaur.
Wait, get on the floor.
Everybody walk the dinosaur.
Those telltale, telltale, is it tale, telltale, telltale?
Telltale Salmon Max Games, I've been on my to-do-to playlist
since they came out.
How long ago was it?
I thought you hated that song.
I hate it because it tells you about, it's not even about
like liking the dinosaurs, it says get rid of the dinosaurs.
My personal suggestion for telltale games is tales.
Oh yeah!
Tales from the Borderlands.
If I didn't do the Wolf Among Us, I was going to do the
Borderlands one.
because, but the reason I didn't do the borderlands one is
because it had more chapters.
I didn't think I would have time to finish it.
So, survival.
We're playing again.
Manage, yeah, we're gonna do all the normal things like
health and oxygen and stuff.
Beyond the telltale game, Sam and Max is also a comic
cartoon.
LucasArts point and click.
Who is Sam and Max?
Who are those guys?
The flight to the desert world, Zezuda, will last 14 years.
It is a one-way trip.
When you awaken, your new life begins.
Just a couple of guys.
One's a dog and one's a rabbit.
Oh, that's cute.
Select Pioneer to print.
Whoa!
Wait, I can customize my person?
Well, I gotta be green.
wait but I can customize you oh wait oh I can choose anyone
to be green and then my suit too oh wait but I gotta be
green wait what's the point this is like the least
customizable ever this is you get four people early
access wait can I spin them around no I can't even see the I
can't determine based on booty.
Um...
Hmm...
Oh, I thought he was just so skinny, but his like sides
blend into the...
Oh, they put...
I was like, dang!
Dang, this guy's so skinny!
Booty-less customization.
How am I supposed to make a good judgment if I can't cannot
see the booty.
How am I supposed to make a... My... My... Like... How am I
supposed to decide?
I'm literally stuck.
He has a snatched voice.
Yeah, he do.
This guy's got a little bit more of the grabbable hips.
She's thick, though.
She's thick.
Wise girl.
Speak your truth.
We use... I imagine she probably has the best booty.
I'm a 3D printed person!
It's so bright.
Warning.
Atmospheric pressure above human maximum.
Protected lifespan.
13 minutes.
Adaptation required.
Open my PDA.
Altera.
Whoa.
Pressure tolerance.
Oh yeah, my oxygen is literally zero right now.
Adaptation.
Oh.
We gotta go!
Or I'm gonna die!
Oh, there was one right there too.
Oops.
I took the longer way.
Oh, just kidding.
Uh, let's go to the middle.
Guiz?
Boot?
I am Noah.
You are the QI.
Your life is my job.
My job is your life.
Wow.
I wish I could make full introductions, but courtesy must
wait.
We are both going to die if we stay here.
There's another Noah node in the life pod outside.
and I can get us both to safety.
Download the Noah image.
You are burning in slow motion.
Slow motion.
Under 60 atmospheres of pressure.
Oxygen becomes a neural toxin.
Nitrogen bubbles saturate your flesh and pry your joints
apart.
I've opened the door to the adaptation chamber.
Your printed body can borrow tricks from indigenous life.
You'll feel better.
You'll be better.
The last pioneer didn't make it to the life pod.
I'm activating their black box signal.
You will make it.
That's why you were the QI All right, I think you're talking
a lot for somebody that says we don't have much time to lose
No, my death
Holy moly Your body can adapt to survival traits from
assessor and rat Proceed to the sampling pavilion.
Oh rat
I'm just gonna I'm gonna stick my hand in here.
It feels like I must stick my hand in the pod.
Adopting trimethylamine N-oxide synthesis.
Pressure tolerance increased.
Yeah.
Yippee!
This orb is now your relative.
Sister.
Brother?
Sibling.
Also try, princess, thank you!
Games are fun, but we're drawn by the entertainer.
You!
Me.
You.
My fingers dotted again?
Oh, that hurts.
Ouch.
Owey.
We're fine.
Oni-chan!
This is my brother.
Let's get the distraction flair.
Whoa!
Sick tricks!
What's that?
Oh, the black box is over there, okay.
Can I put this in my inventory?
Can I change my inventory?
Who are you?
You.
But I don't want to... I don't want to... Oh, Ignite is...
Okay, right.
Everybody's got finger tricks today.
What happened to this place?
A little spooky.
What is this?
Oh, I'm just pulling levers.
Okay.
Thank you.
Can I get in one of these?
It seems necessary.
Amphora sponge.
This is spooky.
Yeah, I think it's broken.
Maybe.
Hmm.
Very cool.
Cool start of the game.
Wow!
Oh!
The depth gauge activated.
A serious accident has occurred.
Your sleep.
bay has been separated from the cicada you must reach the
surface and send a distress call black box set reprint point
oh okay interesting my bio bed what's going on this is a
crazy start done thank you the sleep bay was extremely
confined assess mission state asses my full name is noetic
advisor node isv c-i-d-s-b-3 between us i prefer noah you
are the qi the qualified investigator wear it with pride we
have made violent planet fall i don't know the status of the
pioneer colonists the cicada this guy is the 40 000 souls
support the colonists stored in sleep bay three but if
things go wrong i am authorized to print a qi or two for
troubleshooting if we're going to complete the mission to
build a human future on this world you will have to lead the
way are you ready to begin sure i can't release the life pod
the clamps have corroded shut the tyranny of matter you'll
have to swim out and release them Oh, okay.
They're on the back of the pod outside the passenger window.
Mind your breath.
The sound and the...
Is it me or is this the...
This and what he's saying don't match up.
Am I crazy?
Oh, I could...
Oh, give me one second.
I know we're in like peril right now, but I just gotta
change how I look real quick.
Yeah, they don't match.
Okay, that's what I thought.
Uh, where am I headed to, though?
Oh, there's this thing!
Uh, oh, let's view it.
Black Box.
Unable to identify Black Box, invalid header.
Post-mortem.
The pioneer died of drowning.
They became disoriented and ran out of air.
They died alone.
Time of death unknown.
Reprints date unknown.
Continuity determination unknown.
So they want me to do these things, but like, where are
they?
The clamps, what they said?
On the other side of the hatch?
Is this a thing?
Oh, that looks like it, yeah.
Alright, there's one.
And maybe we can get a second one.
Whoa!
Is that all of them?
Oh, prepare for launch!
Okay.
Yippee!
Oh, no!
Oh, that's a person.
Wait, did you guys see that?
Collision.
Thrusters disabled.
Clearing main thrusters.
Stand by.
Whoa.
Dead person?
Thruster function restored.
Brace for creative re- I feel like- we're about to see a
giant eyeball or something you know oh gosh i don't think we
should increase if there's everything is going bad oh
unknown worlds presents wake up oh Nice.
Star Nav does not recognize the sky.
Too bright.
Hi, H.
Ah.
Titan class biosignature on the horizon.
That's sick.
Oh, and here we are.
You are not on Zezura Pioneer.
Oh, I did it again.
Cool!
Everything is customized.
Our fabricator!
This is how we make stuff!
And storage?
Oh, we got some nutrients and health.
Alright!
What's in the colony?
It's your best chance of survival.
A prolonged search will require food and water.
What's in here?
Barnacles.
Barnacles!
I'm already here.
in scary noises let's pick up some stuff can i open this up
hmm we want like our scanner no haha barnacles oh seawater
sampling detects a source of genetic adaptations in this
region so let's see what we can make anyway activity at the
same source we can make fins the air tank that's like
something like that is huge we need that we'll pin that
survival multi-tool oh that's that's good too though the
scanner scanner here we go basic battery air bladder rapid
flotation bladder for emergency s ah i see there's i feel
like we need everything what is that Grease?
Huh.
Why is it like...
Oh, corrupted.
Fully...
Requires fully functional fabricator.
Ah, I see.
Okay.
How do we fix our fabricator anyway?
Survival guide?
This isn't, Seizura.
I thought you should discover that for yourself.
Investigator.
There should be a colony waiting for us.
Your fellow pioneers.
You need a base.
My fellow Noah nodes.
Working together to break ground for the...
who still sleep instead silence not even the cicada answers
why is cicada like the little little stars the standard
survival guide while you pioneer the area and fabricate your
tools i'll apply myself to the life pod sensors okay all
right nerd get on it so for now we'll just swim around look
what we got get some supplies Is this a supply?
Eww!
Ew!
Someone made it stinky in there?
I'm gonna- This organism filters Brian into drinkable fresh
water.
This may be an adaptation to the seawater's anomalously high
vinyl load.
We have nothing to defend ourselves or not.
How do I supposed to open these?
Oh, oxygen.
Thank you.
What the heck is that?
Is that a fish?
Or...
I think so.
Huh?
I'm afraid of whatever...
It's a big floater.
What leviathans we're gonna get in this game?
Let's put our...
Actually, let's put this in here.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Open.
We'll put this in there.
I'll put this in there.
Oh, it's a distraction flare.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then digestive compatibility.
We'll just put him in there as well for this.
Yeah.
Wavy rainbow pattern at the bottom of the ocean is so pretty
in this game.
It is, right?
The game looks so good.
Oh, yeah, look at that.
Well...
Wow!
So, oh, there's some more... some more stuff.
Is this another sea slug guy?
Yoink!
What's this?
Well, we need food food too, no?
Let's go up before...
I'm hearing all sorts of noises!
It's scary!
You'll be alright, Minto.
You're hydrodynamic as it is.
And what do you mean by that?
The Noetic Advisor has transmitted an alert.
Intrusive and persistent heart icon.
Return to the life pod at your convenience.
Remember that you are in command of the mission.
I like, like, the...
I don't know.
Let's go over there, too, obviously.
But...
Everything...
Look at the...
Look at...
There's, like, little structures and stuff out of the water.
That's pretty different from the first game, I feel.
Whoa!
Play on it!
Probably referring to you being...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Actually, I'm so fast.
I'm so fast in water.
I can doggie paddle.
I can do a mean doggy paddle.
Coral dome.
I don't want to like... Well, this guy will give me water,
which is great, but...
so what did it want me to come back here for the
bio bed I'm monitoring noxiously elevated viral loads in the
seawater heavy metal assays detect bone blistering levels of
cadmium lead and chromium this planet is already talk to
your how we have to know if the life pod bio bed can help
find a convenient way to die your black box will face your
mind to the bio bed I'll print you a new body you can return
to your point of exit to retrieve dropped items regular
reprinting may help slow down environmental contamination
it's not a long-term solution but for now we have to triage
he just told me to K M ish he
said he's just like the kids on tick-tock You're so mean!
That thing looks oddly shaped like a sharp object.
I think he's safe.
Well, what if I want to grab supplies and not do that right
now?
This guy looks kind of stuck.
I'll help him out.
Yoink!
Cooked!
Oh, I can cook them and eat them.
Let's go.
I got you.
I'll rescue you.
We got to cook.
Wow.
There's so much new stuff.
You know?
I mean, if I die, that's part of the mission too, right?
I guess.
The gases.
Everybody else also is.
hated that.
Everybody else also left.
They were like disgusting.
I'm hearing some crazy big noises though.
We're close to that floaty guy.
Is it him?
You hear all this?
I think there's something really big out there.
Is my tummy?
No, no.
I'm not even halfway hungry.
Okay, I'm gonna go return my spoils, and then we're going
to...
Actually, I will consume the water slug.
Ouch!
What do you mean?
I said I could drink the water of the slug!
Oh my god, okay, well...
I'll put this away.
Can I make anything with my limited titanium?
No, I don't have fiber.
We can make them multi-tool!
Let's do that.
Of all the equipment available to clear their frontiersmen,
only this demilitarized switchaxe is approved for colonial
fabrication.
And let's cook this guy.
Oh, now I can make the water.
Ah.
Welcome back, Mito.
Hi.
I missed you.
While you were gone, I graduated from college!
And my second favorite BA character's birthday too.
Shiroko?
Thanks for being so cute and funny and silly and cute as
always!
Syntax Era, congratulations!
Congratulations!
Minky simulator can't digest anything wild.
Oh, oops.
I can, I can, and I did!
Alright, and...
Ouch!
Adaptation required.
Brace for digestive distress.
Oh no!
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna... I might poopy my pants.
That'd be so embarrassing.
I finally land on...
I get on a new life.
I get on a new planet.
The first thing I do.
That's so embarrassing!
All the fish are gonna see!
Everybody's gonna know!
They're gonna be like, that's the guy that just arrived!
And he already did that!
Wait, but it said that if I cooked it, I would be able to
eat it.
This game is such a liar.
Okay, um, we have to go die.
I wonder if we'll lose our multi-tool if we do.
Wait, yeah, I'm going the right way.
Sun's going down.
I know.
Don't be so embarrassed.
What is that?
Oh, there's multiple.
I wonder what's something that I can use my tool on.
Oh, oh!
That's one thing about these games.
It's like the world building in them is kind of insane, you
know?
Wait, I wonder...
Oh, this is just coral.
I wonder if I can use this the boxes now that I think about
it yeah the crates yeah yeah yeah let's see if we can oxygen
they did want me to die I will in a second I'm busy I'm busy
I'm busy being good at the game is that you do you make that
noise is this silver what this house contains dead coral
polyps it may have formed on or near our I know I saw one
over here.
Who's rumbling?
Whoa!
Don't get sucked in there.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait.
I think I'm getting sucked.
No.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Let's go find a crate.
Oh, here's one.
It won't let me...
Hmm.
Nope.
I guess not that.
Only specific.
stuff I can break.
Oh, that's so lame.
Oh, wait.
Maybe... Oh.
That was best.
I'm not making fun of me.
Oxygen.
Does not seem to be the case.
That's fine.
What about you?
Oh, I'm gonna catch you.
Whatever the heck that was.
Okay, something is really making a lot of... Okay, we're
gonna go die.
Things are making so crazy what is this potential donor
found suit surface detects molecules matching the organism
from the sleep bay there is food where
is it going wait that's my that's my brother this is my
brother i have a piece of this brother into my hand to the
brother Oh my digestion!
Yes, I can eat all of these critters.
Ah!
Trauma detected.
Flares may distract attacking predators.
He left.
He's afraid of me.
Because he knows I can eat him.
We are stronger.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Ha ha ha ha.
Okay.
I picked up this one guy.
It doesn't seem like I can eat him at all, though.
Who was somebody that I could eat?
What about this guy?
This guy seems pretty hefty.
A wax moon.
I think he's invincible.
Why is this sunset so scary?
Stop!
I'm just whacking them.
Did we get anything with the quartz?
Copper.
Acidic rayon pouch.
That's how we get the battery.
Okay.
Distraction flare.
Oh, we did get some quartz.
Okay, good.
Should we die?
Is this something I whack?
Yes.
Very good.
Oh, these games are so cool at night.
You know?
Ouch!
Oops.
Okay, don't touch it.
This guy, though, I can turn into water.
Yeah, yeah.
Give me a little...
Come here.
What?
Come here, little slugs.
You all belong to me.
Okay.
There's so much I hear going around.
It's so scary.
What's that?
Wait, is this one of the floaters?
Oh, it is!
Wait, he's so cool.
If I die, I die.
In this case, I wonder who between Minky and the character
can hold the breath under the water longer?
Well, I don't have to breathe.
I am a ghost.
Tracking a bloom with viral activity at the same source.
Investigate with caution.
Like down here?
Well, I can't probably go down there.
I'll die.
You know?
What are these, though?
Oh.
Do not hesitate to use alien life forms for survival
purposes.
Oh, I won't.
You always search for unexplainable oxygen.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
I want to go see this guy, though.
It's cool you can change your genetic code by hugging a
giant cell in this game.
Imagine if you had to, I don't know, fight a stinky diving
suit monster man.
Yeah, imagine.
I wonder if we'll see another...
Another brother.
Another sister.
Another sibling of mine.
Everything's all.
That's one thing I love about these games is you always find
like...
Oh, that's pretty deep over there.
You always...
Oh!
Find like the debris and everything.
I kind of have to put together what's been going on.
I'm gonna grab you oh yes my digestion will be able to eat
you yeah yeah I unlocked I unlocked being able to feed wait
where do you go can I like put these in my inventory yeah
there we go wait come back wow wow I want to touch it.
I want to touch his little tentacles.
Yeah, my gut bacteria.
Heisey.
Can I touch it?
Oh, nothing happens.
Everything glows though.
I'm wondering what's making like the really nasty growl.
I wonder if it's like that guy or something.
The nighttime is so pretty, isn't it?
Yeah.
Let's try and find some more supplies on the way down.
Can I like beat this up?
No, it's just some coral.
Oh.
I'm going up!
That guy!
Friendly?
Wait, what is that thing anyway?
Whoa!
Is this guy friendly?
Are you friend?
Friend?
Wait, what is this?
Ox?
Oh, it gives you oxygen!
Oh, friend?
For a- Ouch!
Wait!
Ouch!
An actual nerd.
Wait, is it sunrise already?
Good morning, ninto.
Eat it.
Yeah, he's mine now.
Hmm.
We got to build some more stuff.
Let's get in here.
Oh, wait, there's some more...
Uh...
Like, we really need to build, like, the things that will
let us in the water longer.
This is just quartz and stuff.
We need...
Oh, what's over here, actually?
This looks good.
Colony structure located.
There may be clues to the location of the main habitat.
Yoink.
Wait, is this, oh, this is all underwater still?
Node!
No power!
Wait, what's this?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, nice!
Oh, huge!
What's this?
Programmable detonator!
Habitat Builder.
I'll take that.
And I'll take that.
Thank you.
And what is this?
Oxygen can be used to make basic chemical batteries.
Oh, nice!
Oh, nice.
Oh, wait.
We gotta grab these.
My inventory's full.
Give me the oxygen.
Thank you.
That was a nice little find.
Wait, so let's go back.
I wish I could sprint.
Speed swim.
Yeah, good all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just kick harder.
Yeah, you can later, yeah.
You have to, like, make everything.
Metal salvage.
And we can make all of our good cooked food.
We can eat.
Make some water.
Yeah.
I turned those slugs into water bottles.
The technology is crazy.
Can we have some?
Yeah.
Say ah.
I give you slug.
Mild acid.
We need copper for that.
But I really want to...
Oh, see like the thing's like...
Glass.
Fibrish pulp.
Rubber!
We can make a rubber.
Huge because now we have another rubber!
Rubber!
We're the fins.
Oh, okay, good, good.
Now we just gotta make fiber, which is we need the fibrous
hope.
And the battery is for the air tank.
No, it's for the scanner.
And we need titanium and silver.
Okay.
We're working on it.
We're working.
Let's go.
That'll salvage rubber.
Oops, I didn't mean to put my water away.
There we go.
Okay.
You can get fiber from the cups that hold the rubber pods.
Okay, we gotta find a rubber pod.
A rubber pod.
First time seeing Minton 3D on normal livestream.
Well, to be honest, I really haven't used it.
I think this is like one of the first times I've kind of
used it for just like a normal stream like this.
I think.
Why does everybody say I sound like a Rugrats?
You know you were not the first time to say that I sound
like a Rugrats character.
If only I were dead back then.
I think that I would have been assigned, I would have been
on the Rugrats show.
Maybe.
But oftentimes, I'm told.
Wait, is someone gonna...
What's down there?
Wait.
Flashlight.
Wasn't there...
Ouch!
What are you?
Toxic sponge.
Get rid of it.
Get rid of it?
Okay, never mind.
We can't do that.
Not yet, I guess.
Oh, there's tons of stuff down here, though.
Uh-oh.
Bacterial action creates copper on cave roofs and
overnights.
Okay.
Back down.
You gotta be fast.
Ew!
Ouch!
The portable locker can be hand-carried or attached to a
hole.
I'm really taking some crazy damage here.
Oh, nice!
Metal salvage.
We got some good stuff here.
Sippy sip.
Chompy chomp.
Nice.
Uh...
How do I... Oh, drop it?
Wait, but it's gonna sink, no?
Carry it.
Drop it.
How am I supposed to kill these things?
They're disgusting.
I'm looking around to see if I...
Oh wait!
Aha!
Let's see if anything towards the top.
Nice!
We don't...
I think that will suck us in, no?
Ooh.
The noetic advisor has transmitted an alert.
Ah!
Return to the life port.
Okay.
Oxygen.
Maybe you need something stronger than the hammer.
Wait, am I at my life?
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I'm here.
Ouch!
Ouch.
Oh.
Maybe I'm supposed to...
I'm supposed to destroy these before I take the acid.
Maybe I did that in the wrong order.
The sound is so funny though.
Habitat filter.
What's in here?
So curious to know.
I will return on my own convenience when I feel like it.
Am I directionally challenged?
No.
I'm not, but also I'm exploring.
I know it's right there.
Yeah.
I'm just exploring.
I'm exploring.
I'm doing what the game wants you to do.
That looks like a scrap metal.
Oh, yes!
I knew it.
Is this?
Yes.
Metal salvage.
that looks awfully big open block of food
I feel like these games start out they're always like quite
like a slow start you know what I mean a calorie mate yeah
these games always have a bit of a slow star but then like
once you start building your base and everything They start,
it starts rolling.
I don't mind that, though.
Boink.
Are you mad about that?
Oh, you're fast.
Recommend scanner.
I'm trying to get this stuff.
I'm trying.
I mean, we need more titanium.
Oh, my inventory's full.
It is?
Oh, my hand!
My hands are free!
Can I go in underneath?
Oh, not yet.
Okay.
Maybe I have to build that.
I remember it was like that in the first game.
Let's see.
We're for the fiber.
And silver!
Okay.
We can do the air bladder, but I don't want to waste the
rubber.
The battery?
What do we need for the battery?
Oh!
need some more copper we can get that we can we can fake
okay we can make the scanner we can make the scanner for
sure what is this a key metal salvage i'm almost out of
space the bladder's really good isn't it is it just a
one-time use or can i use it several times okay copper i
think i see me Nice.
That was fast.
You can consistently use it?
Oh, I didn't make it because I thought it was one-time use.
Copper.
Now we're talking.
Oxygen.
I'm going.
Refills when you refill the oxygen.
Oh, sick.
Let's go.
huh all right let's make us a battery oh wrong thing
okay and then let's make us a scanner nice stranded on 4546b
riley robinson used a field scanner to outwit teleporting
alien cyborgs and treat his carra infection debate why Riley
abandoned a lucrative motivational speaking career to return
to frontier life the
first game I didn't remember his name the first game gets so
crazy like actually we'd be scanning how do I scan scan
everything scan
Scan everything.
ABS, always be scanning.
Did I get him?
No, I don't think so.
Wait, I want to...
There was a...
There was a cave right underneath our...
Oxygen.
Okay, I'll go up.
Scan anomaly, bottom right?
Here.
Oh, wait.
wish to venture into here.
Oh, did I miss that?
Nice.
Wait, did I scan that guy before?
I don't think so.
That's okay.
This colony of worms in a shared membrane will be super
earthly analog.
You have discovered a new clade.
Naming rights may be auctioned off or reserved as a gift for
that special someone in your future me i get to name him
let's grab this okay we're just gonna drop that real quick
um yoink yoink yoink oh my inventory's full already oh my
goodness i'm gonna stay right here so we can all right open
the inventory
Because I keep grabbing slugs.
Wait.
We'll drink this.
We'll consume.
Consume.
Wait.
Oh, you're in the way.
Carry.
Alright.
Drop.
Let me have some more oxygen, please.
Eww!
Scanner.
Drinking water underwater.
Yeah, but it's like...
It's, it's, it's different because it's, uh...
It's a...
You know.
It's not sea water.
What's that?
Just a plant.
What's in here?
Can I finish scanning before?
Okay.
Mimic pylon.
The kelp.
Get some kelp.
Hmm.
Is there still more over there?
The welcome center.
I feel so welcome.
You also say Abyscanon, aka Abyss.
Yeah, actually.
IBS.
Silver.
Haven't been able to find silver yet.
And the fiber.
Fibrous pulp.
Mild acid.
I wonder what we could use this for.
Oh.
Strong acid unlocked.
Yep.
pulp from the cradles.
You left the box behind.
Wait, there was a box down there?
Oh, oh, you mean like the my storage, yes.
I did leave my little guy behind.
Scanning anomaly in the lower right.
Huh.
Oh, there's some copper right there, though.
I feel like I need to pick up...
I'm...
I'm picking up materials but not the stuff that I need hold
on the noetic advisor has transmitted an alert return to the
life port at your convenience oh that's right yeah what you
see what you need chap oh wait the missing colonists too I
printed 26 colonists before the I go thank you many of them
more than once this is my purpose to reincarnate you from
digital storage support your work and if necessary reverse
your death if I lose track of my colonists I am empowered to
send a qualified investigator to track them down do this for
me and I can offer you hazard pay credit against your
contract I'm just a 3d printed person see her ordinal
warrant too I am already You're searching for the black
boxes of the missing colonists.
Stand by for search locations.
Downloading colony manifest to your PDA.
Okay.
Another black box.
Chap Savon.
Head of computational dynamics.
His job is to make sure I'm doing my job.
Okay.
I'm what he would call weekly superfluous.
Yeah, well, I only went at a time.
It means I respond well to human guidance.
I can take partial instructions.
I have to listen to his final breaths.
Jack gave you his PDA pass key so you could play games on
this account.
Oh, yes!
His action was against the rules, but in support of the
concept.
The title, thank you so much for the fight, get there!
Thank you!
We got games!
Oh yeah.
yeah oh I'm trying to get my arms up oh oh yeah we got games
on the phone let's put my nutrient block away and this guy
away what else can we make that I have so much stuff you
know I got them oh the air bladder let's make that yes okay
Perfect.
So we have that.
That got rid of a bunch of titanium, I think.
Wish stuff could stack.
Oh, wait!
We're looking for silver.
I wonder if I need to go down further for it.
You know?
Is this silver?
Copper.
The hedgehog?
Silver the hedgehog?
Oh my gosh!
When I...
I was...
When we were all...
When Densetsu, when we were all hanging out, Vicky looked at
me and she was like, How did you know?
And I was like, What do you mean?
How did I know?
She was like, How did you know that my Sonic Sona looked
like that?
And she was like, I was watching your Tomodachi life.
And my Sonic Sona Looks so similar To how you made Vicky In
Tomodachi Life I didn't know I think I'm just that I'm that
entuned Maybe I had no idea You wouldn't download and 3D
print a Minto right?
I've kind of been wanting to do that though Make like a 3D
Printable Minto design or Aibu Design.
I've thought about that.
Guys, where can I get?
Wait.
How do we get in there?
Whoa, it's like popping up chemicals and stuff.
Clearly we can break these down, huh?
Or we could just swim inside.
Never mind.
Maybe.
How do I find silver?
Oxygen.
Silver.
I was printed a little Ibu figurine and passed them out at
Phantom Thieves Revenge.
It's so cute.
I actually, I carry one around with me always.
I do carry one around with me.
Little Ibu.
So there is the welcome.
center.
I don't know if we still need to do anything with that.
But silver.
Maybe we need to go down further.
I'm going in.
I'm a little frightened, but I'm doing it.
What is bloom sap?
I'm scanning?
I'm not scanning.
I'm inhaling.
How do I... Oh, maybe I can Cut it.
Ah!
Ew.
Is all that was in there?
A flashlight.
Okay, hold on.
We need to refill my bloom.
Or my thing.
We need to refill my...
My bladder.
Okay.
Alright, go back.
Let's scan.
See if we can scan.
thing down here.
Oh, why did it get so dark?
Like that.
Wait, why does it look like this?
Is this not good for me?
Does they don't want me down here?
Maybe?
Yeah, but...
Okay.
Ah.
Too spooky.
Dark vision, yeah.
Hmm.
What if I go in here, though?
Are you mean?
What is that?
Oh, no.
This is an oxygen thing, though.
Yeah.
Can I have some?
May I...
You're nice.
He totally ignored me.
Thank you, okay.
Inside here is...
Isn't this where I was before?
I'm getting lost in the sauce.
There is no sign of plant life on this world.
This waxy fiber is closer to vinyl, organitex, and
cellulose.
Oh!
Oh, we got some!
Good, good, good, good.
Wait, this is the stuff we needed!
Oh, nice!
This is the stuff we needed.
Yes!
I think?
Right?
Okay, remember that area.
Oh, nice.
I think we can make the flippers now.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
All plants give fiber.
Wait.
How do I know what does a plant?
Blonking everything.
Yes.
Okay.
Alright, we're getting somewhere.
plant right here?
Can I bonk this guy right now?
This looks like coral.
That's coral.
Plant equals not rock or coral.
I just noticed there's like that wire there.
I wonder if that's how we restore the power.
All right.
Making me some flippy flippers.
Yes!
I need another rubber.
How did I make the rubber again?
Oh, yes!
Just kidding.
We're making some flippers right now.
Nice.
Now if I can just make the silver, we will be so good.
I'll make some cook food.
Do these go bad?
I wonder.
Wait.
What do I eat you?
Uh.
They don't go bad.
Oh, that's acid.
That's not water.
Don't drink that.
Probably.
Let's turn some more things into water.
Okay.
Good, good, good.
Don't drink the acid.
That should be like, you know, like, when you die at a game,
and they sometimes give you those helpful hints that are
just like, try dodging.
One of them should be like, don't drink acid.
We'll just keep making water.
Helpful hints.
I always get you rationally angry at those because it's
always such like common sense things they're making a
mockery of you they're saying they're saying you're bad at
the game actually corals kelp sponges are not plants today I
learned we'll drink some water oh Is there like a...
Oh, it's taking it from my... Oh, I'm understanding more.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm understanding more about how this works.
Let's see.
Okay, so, rubber.
Which we need more of this Lucifer rotsak.
And...
Okay.
Can you stack air bladders?
That's kind of crazy.
Everybody hide.
Me too.
I also hydrate.
Yeah, the glowy yellow balls.
Yes, yes.
Which I might have in here.
Um.
Let's see what I got.
Probably should just start taking my stuff from here.
I have a...
I really wish things would stack, though, in this game.
We have a lot of copper now.
Consumables.
We can make more distraction flares?
First aid kit.
I have to...
Copper wire.
Let's try making it.
Wiring kit!
I need silver for it though.
And I also have this over here.
Did it automatically put on my flippers?
I'll leave this here for now.
Oh, it did?
Okay, good.
Let's go see where this wire goes to.
Nasty.
Oh, does it go to over here?
Okay.
The satisfying music when you make new stuff.
You're right, though.
Let's scan this guy.
He's cool.
The scanning, I feel, takes a long time, but...
Okay, we got some of those.
Does it go anywhere else?
No, just here?
Ooh.
Hmm.
Is there anything else I can do in here?
Retro Rewide mod gal here.
Already modding some too!
No way!
Am I gonna be...
Swimming, swimming, in the ocean blue.
The days are hot, the water's cool, in the ocean blue.
Uh, front, stroke, back, stroke, fancy diving tool.
That's the way I want to.
Wait, how does it go?
Something, something, something.
Quartz, quartz, and quartz.
But where's all the silver?
Where's the valuables?
Where are the valuables?
Okay.
Okay, good.
There is like the...
I wanted to see if like pressing two, you know, would...
So three...
Can I scan you?
Hammer head.
Not me!
Ah!
Woo!
Okay, we're fine.
Something's purple in here.
Oh!
Uh, this stuff.
Oxygen.
Ouch!
You stupid!
He gets always gets one hit in and then just leaves.
I guess I should probably try dying, but...
I'm gonna find silver first.
Wait, wait.
What's this?
Is this anything?
Oh.
Who's there?
Holy cow.
Something's making a lot of noise.
What's this over here?
What do we got?
A wall rack?
Can I scan this for how to make it?
Ah, okay, okay.
Wait, so then I can scan...
Yeah!
I forgot!
That's how you did it!
That's how you made the stuff!
Titanium ingot.
There's a lot of sounds going on.
This gives a hickey and bales.
How lude!
I guess... Oh, it doesn't want me to go to the black box for
chap.
Ouch!
Stop!
Where'd he go?
how do i to find silver though please please i just want
some silver oh is this kind of far down though it seems like
maybe let me deep in there
yeah i remember now i remember go to the deep please some
silver it must be in the deep right
Oh, what's over here?
What are you?
Okay, that's not that deep.
I think.
What's over here?
Let's scam some more stuff.
Yes, yes.
Oh, oh, oh!
Wake up.
Okay, to a...
Something large is moving.
Something large is moving?
What do you mean by that?
Oh.
I don't like that.
Imagine if Mickey holds her breath every time she goes
under.
Immersive role play stream.
But then...
That means...
I also get to take a breath every time I get one of these
bad boys.
Wait, so in...
Where's the...
In here?
Maybe?
This looks like silver.
Silver!
Requires unknown tools.
What the heck are you?
I found it.
Chap!
This is where he was, old chap!
Old chap!
Repair tool.
Nice.
Use a bio bed.
Oh, awesome!
Scan the bio bed.
Scan everything.
Can we open that?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
What do you want?
You can see.
My mouth is full of holes.
You have a brand new body.
be a little stronger a little faster the biobed's got you
until it all happens again the metal or the maze field this
planet is poison we're doing just fine it works we can slow
down you can scan the bed okay i will anyways
i'm gonna scan your single bed single bed one out of two
No, it's titanium.
What are you?
Oh, the salt!
I can make some more stuff now.
How exciting.
Nutrients.
Okay.
This is a big copper also.
We need a new tool!
Hold on, I'm gonna go back in here.
Okay.
Let's go.
New tool for our...
Oh, what is that?
Oh, that's an oxygen guy.
What are you?
Wait, is this...
This is probably not silver.
But if on the off chance that it is.
Orch.
Can I scan you?
Ooh.
Okay.
What kind of new tool can I even unlock?
At this point.
What is that?
Oh my god!
Whoa!
Hermit Crab!
Coral Crab!
He's so cute.
You think he likes me?
We're buds, we're buds.
Oh, they're swarming me right now?
Oh, I don't think they like me.
Okay, I'm leaving.
Where's my home?
Oh, this way.
Nice.
This lad is so cute.
Don't swarm me.
I'm heading home.
Oh, now there's like more things.
Woo!
We almost got caught in the current.
I'm too good.
Maybe whatever we make next, we'll be able to kill those
nasty sponges, too.
I don't think I got the ability to make anything, though.
Nothing new, I think.
Oily salad!
Oh, boy!
My favorite!
Oily salad!
So glad I can make that now.
Yummy scrumptility dumptious.
Yeah, what tools can we make?
See, nothing new besides the scanner and the multi-tool.
What was the rubber?
Oh, here we go.
I still need a silver though.
Let's make some distraction flares.
scan more stuff in crates yeah yeah now that i remember that
i can scan things in crates because there was like
flashlight and stuff too now that i remember that i scan
those to make them i i feel you know like i can do that uh
let's drink some water consume and let's eat nutrient blah
or no we'll eat this guy first
okay very good
because my inventory is like completely full for the most
part wait i'll make some more rubber can't i or fiber we'll
make fiber um
salt i'm trying i don't want to lose the stuff that we've
made You know what I mean?
So let's take out like some of these things.
We'll put them in.
Put you away.
Put you...
No, we'll hold on to you.
Put you away.
And my flares are down there.
Let's go scan some stuff.
From the crates that I missed.
Anything here?
Nothing.
Oh, wait, this opens.
Oh, okay, I'll take that.
Uh...
Yeah, I completely forgot that I needed to scan, like,
things to unlock the recipes.
Let's go scambling!
Oh, come on.
Actually, let's go back to the welcome center.
There was a bunch of stuff...
Where was that?
Oh
yeah!
Be back!
I mean back!
Uh, back!
Throw it.
Wait, can I scan you?
Since you're like, oh, I'm gonna scan the nibbler mango.
I think he's just...
He's a little...
He's a little confused.
Uh, okay, this way.
Welcome center Back demon back I don't think I killed him
definitely Was just a little I mean he now knows who's he
who he's messing with When you mess with the minke you get
you catch these hands and You catch these the You catch my
flares I wonder if I can scan this thing That'd be nice to
be able to create some lamps.
No?
Wait, what was that?
Sea branching core.
Interesting.
Let's go up again for oxygen.
When you mess with the minke, you get the stinky.
That's actually been my catchphrase.
Day one.
Oh, like this.
Here we go.
Habitat builder.
Okay.
We've seen a couple of them.
these.
I just have to find the other ones.
So that I can scan them.
Dining table.
No power.
What do you need?
Biolab.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, Biolab unlocked!
Okay, very cool.
Was there anything else in here?
Oh, Habitat Builder!
There's the other one.
We'll unlock new fabricator recipes.
But the added mass will sink your life cord.
A standalone habitat is the next step on your mission.
Nice!
Was there anything else down here?
Okay.
Did I scan these guys?
Yeah.
It's time to build!
Wow.
Uranus is beautiful.
Thank you.
Are you the owner of Uranus?
My bangs are looking cute today?
How can you tell?
They're a little flowy.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da!
Habitat builder!
Oh, glass!
We can make that.
Glass.
Just like that bird.
You too.
Stub it.
Oh.
Uh...
Habitat builder!
Very nice.
You have taken a major step towards zero debt day.
As a platform for systems like the processor and scanner
station.
a habitat is a vital investment in your future a habitat can
also be an emotional anchor proof that you've built
something to last remember it's easier to replace a body
than a base where's the toes look down hauntingly ethereal
one might say
Oh, bio bed test.
What is this?
I'm monitoring noxiously elevated viral loads in seawater.
Heavy metal assays detect bone blistering levels of cadmium,
lead, and chromium.
This planet is already killing you.
We have to know if the life pod bio bed can help.
Find a convenient way to die.
Oh, that's right.
Your black box will phase your mind to the bio bed.
I'll print you in a new body.
Okay.
You can return to your point of exit to return.
tree of dropped items.
Regular reprinting may help slow down environmental
contamination.
It's not a long-term solution.
One more thing you can build before you base build.
What's that?
Um, no way!
I'm gonna die on purpose!
I understand.
Oh.
That's it.
That's all.
No way, Jose!
He says.
Oh, guys.
What else can we build?
Scanner, Habitat Builder, Air Bladder, Survival, Multitool.
I don't see anything else.
Unless?
Am I missing?
Marco!
Thank you so much for the vlog.
Thank you!
And see how they give it to Super Chat.
I think the 3D really brings out my eyes.
I hope everything is going well.
Yeah, I'm having fun.
Thanks.
If you say yes, it probably just a tutorial on how to
respawn.
Make another battery and look around the welcome center
more.
You miss something important.
Thanks for the hint.
Well, uh, I gotta get some copper.
Let me go.
I think I have some right in here, actually.
Oh, just kidding, it's empty.
Let's check this one.
Before I, like, go pick up some new stuff, you know.
Aha!
We'll just take this all home with me.
Easy, baby.
Battery and welcome center.
Mm-mm-mm.
fish in water stream.
Wahoo!
Minto just got hit with the K.
I know!
I don't think he cares about me at all.
Let's drink some water.
Real quick.
But also, my habitat.
Enter.
Move mode.
Open menu.
Corridor!
Oh!
Like this.
And like a...
Wait, can the hatch be on the bottom?
Uh, open menu.
Must be attached to a room or corridor.
Aw, I mean.
Okay.
Oh, fabricator.
Wall locker, floor locker, ceiling light.
Bio bed.
That's this.
No?
Yeah.
Noah terminal.
Solar panel.
Whoa.
Habitat beacon.
Generates a signal to help you locate your habitat.
Oh, now we can finally build the lockers.
Oh, nice.
The portable locker.
And we can also get more storage.
Okay, cool.
We just gotta build our location out a little bit.
Yeah, BioBit is the respawn point.
Scanner.
Welcome center.
Okay.
Yes!
I got the battery!
Yeah, I got it right there.
What did I miss?
In here.
Anything up here?
Oh, uh, no, that's a dome.
Small light.
That's another thing.
Uh, hold on.
I'm gonna wait for more oxygen.
Okay.
Uh, gamers don't look up.
This thing I was trying to...
Ah!
All systems online.
Power connected.
Whoa!
We used the biolab.
What is this?
Pathfinder Oh, I can really Sparrowman's Oh my Sea skimmers
Simpaster when close to underwater surfaces Or seafloor
Slows oxygen consumption when not moving Sure?
Activate biomod Wow!
Wait, what did I...
Actually, what did I just attach to myself?
Dash in any direction to avoid predators or hazards.
What the heck?
Sea skimmer.
Maybe that one instead of the oxygen.
I feel like I'm moving around too much for...
Whoa!
Does it use more oxygen?
Boot Noah.
Hacker voice.
This structure was connected to Sleep Bay 3 until the base
suddenly moved.
Picked up and hurled a full fathom into the deep with you
and I aboard.
20,000 hours earlier, a hard line leading to a habitat
complex in the north was deliberately cut.
Why?
And if I am not mistaken, and I never am, this node was
killed by an explosion below the structure.
for the qualified investigator i've retrieved two messages i
think you should review them i remember sophie very fondly
oh yeah luckily oxygen isn't consumed while talking i was
definitely looking at my o2 leg um i'm very curious about
alone dot txt and over dot txt but we'll start at
I'm not dabbing.
I was fixing my headphones.
Now the diver of this mess.
Here is my formula for a quick base.
Fill up on titanium, quartz, and copper.
Just casually dabbing.
Get your builder tool.
It wasn't a dab.
Check the battery.
Get comfortable.
Build a corridor.
Put the solar panel on top.
Yeah?
You must have hour to make air.
Oh.
in go inside build lockers uh-huh a fabricator it will draw
from your lockers automatically oh nice huh now you have
made a perfect work camp later you can add a room for bio
bed processor scanner this little scuffed though a real bed
maybe grow some plants the rest will fall still scuffed
sorry my arms don't want to cooperate it nice
biomods yeah this is crazy dab on that dead guy's last
message well less permanent than adaptations I've been told
they're more fun ooh Sophie would have cleared anything in
there who is Sophie alone dot txt what if you're the last
human being in the whole universe Wouldn't that set you
free?
I'm a ghost.
Press Dab to pay respects.
Over.txt.
This world is yours to explore.
But it is not for man.
You'll join us soon enough.
I've made sure of it.
Wait, that part doesn't...
not get spoken it's over we're all gone this world is yours
to explore but it's not for man you'll join us soon enough
I've made sure what do you mean you've made sure of it what
do you mean by that become fish wait it's like that one
what's it called that chill is art game where everybody
became fish personal messages welcome back pioneer I'm
Sophie Boucher Yeah.
Yeah.
We call this planet Proteus.
Proteus.
Some things are better left unspoken.
Among our sleeping friends, we have to learn how to survive.
Hey, fellow dead slave.
I'm Nahima Nakoda, ecologist.
Take a sip of seawater.
Notice that sweet blood taste under the salt.
That's a toxic dose of heavy metals.
Nobody survived past three months.
Seek fresh water intake.
Oh, oh my gosh.
My dang it.
My thing.
Wait, I was listening to that.
Nobody survived past three months.
It's a beautiful place to die over and over again.
I know, perfect timing on that, right?
But don't let that beauty seduce you, pioneer.
Exposure to Proteus causes a delusion we call Macefield
syndrome.
The call of the sea.
Ignore them.
You remember what Kara did to our homes.
You know we can't trust alien biology.
We've set up a lab here with a few basic biomods.
They're safe.
But if you start to hear voices or you get the urge to swim
to the tree...
Don't go.
Habitat is due north.
We'll come pick you up.
See you soon, Pioneer.
The Meretic Advisor has transmitted an alert.
Return to the life port at your convenience.
And drink some water, I guess.
I'm drinking, I'm drinking, I'm drinking on the job.
Can I scan some more, you guys?
Have I scanned you already?
Blue moon.
Unlike Minto Field Syndrome, the call of the stream.
This one must always be obeyed.
Yes.
If you feel like you are if you feel like you are developing
Minto Field Syndrome, do not worry.
It is normal.
You must watch Mint Phantom or else you will die.
I'm just kidding.
Amish?
Let's see now.
Um...
That was a...
What all...
They were telling us to make stuff.
Become ghost.
Did I...
I did grab...
Something, didn't I?
Maybe it was with...
The habitat builder.
We got the fabricator...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
More lights.
A window.
Build a base.
Yes.
What is move mode?
And destruct mode.
Shrink mode.
What is shrink mode?
Bio bed.
No, you don't want to...
Okay.
But it says for the corridor, I need to...
Maybe I need to get some more stuff for like...
Okay.
Oh, I forgot that I had that.
Yeah.
Oh, it's so awesome.
More things to scan.
Dining table we got.
Biolab we got.
What else is in here?
Security cameras!
Which seemingly seems to be...
Oh!
I'll take that.
Whoa!
Whoa, I did not know.
Whoa, this is cool.
We're in the coral dome.
Um.
You missed a few things.
What else did I miss?
Oh, here we go.
Display tank.
I was trying to get that earlier.
This case was broken by a survival multi-tool.
Sabotage is a serious crime.
Samantha Ayu's bombing of Altaira Labs delayed critical
carara research.
Let's get that.
New life poster.
What else can we get?
Gamers don't look up.
Um.
Can I get the large window?
That's a reference to below zero.
That I have not played.
But.
Wait, what is it?
Oh, that's like the suit thing though.
Okay.
What's this?
Alright.
Leave me alone.
Hum.
Okay, so we build a base, but...
I feel like I'm missing a few things to build it.
Where does that just be?
It was not so good.
Oh, really?
Wasn't that good?
I didn't hear that.
So far, this is like very like the original, but just
different enough.
You know what I mean?
It said there was a habitat up north.
It did say that.
That is true.
Surely not this.
Was there...
Oh, let's see if there's something that I forgot to scan
over here too.
Very possible.
Oh, the girls are fighting.
Oh, the girls are fighting!
This is where we learn to digest food like a baby.
Anita!
Wait, did I grab this already?
I must have.
Habitat Builder, we already scanned it, but I'll do it
again.
So that we have it.
Wait, what was that?
I saw something.
Wait, no!
Uh, inhale.
I'm still scanning.
There was something here!
Wait, what was it?
The Titan...
Oh wait, I'm scanning the rock.
Ouch, stop!
I'm doing science.
Rock.
Hey, I got a detonator.
I'm not afraid to use it.
I'm not afraid to get you guys Like I did before.
I freaked you out.
I remember.
Nice.
Let's keep heading north, I guess.
What is this?
What are those?
What is everything?
What is this?
Awake maker!
I don't know what that is, but now we can make it.
Ah!
We're surrounded.
Oh!
Ah!
Stay back!
Yeah, idiots.
What is this?
Maybe we shouldn't be out at night.
It's the big friendly jam.
Big friendly jelly.
Maybe.
What's this?
Oh, another bio bed.
Jelly buddy.
The big effing jelly.
I learned that from...
From...
From Doom.
What is this?
Everything is just...
What crowd?
The new thing.
Whoa.
Oh.
What is our big friendly jelly anyway?
I'm not...
I feel like I'm going...
I'm going north, but I feel like I'm going towards the tree.
Isn't that what I'm not supposed to do?
Well, I guess the tree is a little northeast, but...
Northern direction.
No?
I feel like I'm going...
Oh, we found it!
That's no good.
Right?
Sounds kind of bad.
Sounds like there should be something going on here.
We made it!
If one of my species finds this message...
Me?
You may be the very last human being in the universe.
You get to write the last chapter of our story.
already it up.
I ask you to do the most human thing you can.
Forget your debt.
Forget Noah.
Forget Altair.
I'm debt-free!
Debt doesn't even... That doesn't... That doesn't... It's
just... That's fine.
That's all right.
Pick the most interesting thing you can see and explore.
Whoa.
Can I get in this way?
Guess not.
Um, maybe this way.
There's something else.
Compostion byproducts detected.
Fire is a critical risk in oxygen-rich habitats.
But we're underwater.
Dramatic advisor has transmitted an alert.
Return to the life pod at your convenience.
Wait a second.
day 755.
i think i've cracked it oxygen sophie and anita are both
right the protea virus causes macefield syndrome but only
one kind of protea virus the bloom strain maybe it's
tainting anita's angel comb adaptation i think i've tuned
the sonic resonators to destroy the viral crystals grown by
the bloom strain we should test on the angel combs out west
with those promising heat shock proteins and if i'm wrong
Hey, I'm just a dietitian.
No one should have woken up a virologist.
Oh, we made it.
We're so good.
The potato virus.
We're Irish.
Maybe?
Miko?
Who's that?
That was a close one.
Colonel, we managed to avoid drowning.
There are air-filled sections in there.
Yeah, but I didn't know where.
I couldn't risk it.
My scanner's about to break.
This thing is so flimsy.
Bloom's specimen.
Oh, the cup.
Oh, okay.
Actually, I need to do that for real.
What is this?
Oh, nice.
Chloric intake at the moment, then.
Nice.
You are hungry.
Yeah, I actually am.
Battery terminal.
Okay.
Bio reactor.
We're getting lots of good stuff here.
Table.
Uh...
What is this?
Oh, nice!
A chair.
Scanner station.
Wait.
Oh, yippee!
Chair two out of two.
I know, finally, it can sit in this dang place.
Finally, I can rest my tush.
What's this?
Room recipe data card.
Down.
But no, they
were trying to build a life.
I didn't know Barry was in this game.
40,000 sleeping souls, but they didn't make it.
Were they sick?
Did the Minto field syndrome?
We have to know.
I've activated Dr. Wu Langye's black box.
his work may be your best lead we should salvage what we can
I've retrieved a few files gather all the blueprints you can
especially the scanner station okay I feel like though I
really want to make a thing that I got the scanner station
yeah I really want to make something though that will let me
cicada debris oh a dining table nice our place is going to
be so homey.
But something that will allow me to...
vaguer things.
God,
we're on fire.
I have to go.
Ganso.
Signal everyone outside to rally at the tadpole pens.
I can finally rescue our booty.
Plus two.
Oh, nope, let me...
Oh, nope.
Yeah, get me in there.
What's a pent?
Well, my inventory's full.
I guess we'll never know.
Coral jar...
What's this?
Wait, what did I just do?
Oh.
1200 calories a day.
Foraging won't help.
The only safe food is food we grow in here.
Noah flooded air just in time.
Noah flooded it.
We can never trust the house.
I'm taking survivors due east of the tadpole pens.
Swim down the tunnel past Sophie's office to the baby
jellies.
The baby jellies.
Alright, um...
Let's see.
What else is around here that we can explore bioreactor?
This gives us oxygen.
Delicious, thank you.
We got more in here.
Oh, what's this?
Dining table?
Safety first poster?
These like super...
They're not useless.
They're actually very important to me.
Dining table?
Down.
Stool?
Yeah.
They're very important.
To, for our quality of life.
In our, in our, you know.
Scan process.
Do we have this?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Dining chair.
Our scanner's about to break, though.
Oh, I, I, I somehow scanned the bot.
Oh!
Noah.
Noah, do not open the Seacocks.
Noah?
Acknowledge, please.
We need a new battery.
I can
use the builders for battery.
Where's the battery?
Where do you see the battery is necessary at?
Battery terminal.
Unload or change a battery.
Oh, I see what you mean.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
You were talking about my scanner.
I thought you were talking about.
I don't think I have, actually, what makes the battery?
Can we even make it?
No, I only have, wait, one out of two copper.
Yeah, I only have one copper.
I think I can grab one though, and then be able to make it.
But I would have to use their things, no?
Well, that's good to know, though.
Okay.
What's that?
Oh, my thing is...
Unload the battery.
Wait.
All I have is pulp.
We'll just head back.
That's fine.
We'll head back, because I have more stuff that I want to
build.
I want to start building my base and everything, too.
I don't know why I'm not just a...
There we go.
Welcome back, Minky.
Thank you!
Mint in the water?
This restaurant is fancy.
Oh, because it's like a fresh minted water.
You know what one of my favorite things is recently?
I feel like a lot, or like a couple hotels that I've been to
recently have been doing this.
Um...
Is uh...
They've been putting out like...
Water with like mint or with like fruit in it.
And I am just... I'm just standing in the lobby and I'm
like...
I'm just down in that.
I'm like...
Only me?
Anyone else?
Ah!
Get away!
Where are you?
Oh, jeez, they're all on me.
Hey!
Wait.
Where'd my home go?
Where's my home base?
Wait, what's that?
Oh, there.
Going the wrong way.
You guys are getting me all twisted turned.
What's this, though?
Contact.
Abandoned colony structure partially disassembled.
Oh.
Whoa, it really is.
Something's yelling.
Who is here?
Camp 1.
Hey!
Chill out!
That is the BFJ.
What do we got here, though?
There's so many of these guys.
They're so annoying.
Wait, this one's new.
Oh!
What does that mean?
Ah!
Um, anyway.
I'm going home.
You are being hunted is a terrifying sentence that I would
not like to hear again.
You are being hunted.
Now, why would they say that?
Now, I'm kind of like, not annoyed, but like, I have to go
find all these recipes that I missed before.
Because there was like stuff like flashlights and stuff that
I missed.
You know?
I have to refine oxygen where is my home
there it is
mint is the one who haunts yeah shark just really wanted a
pen light he was kind of cute though after he like he was
like mouth agape just at the at the The distraction flair.
It was kind of cute.
Home sweet home!
Honestly, I started to- I need to get some food made and
stuff too.
And we got this sick- Ceremoia rot sack!
Which we apparently can eat.
Can we eat this?
Let's- Oh, it's a medical gel.
Oh!
Oh, I didn't realize.
Okay, awesome.
How does it taste?
Apparently sweet and delicious.
Full of sweet fluid.
Resembles a cheramoya fruit.
Edible with some spinning.
What does that mean?
Me too cute!
Wait.
Grab, grab, grab, grab, grab, grab.
The sea creature just wanted to learn Otage from the source.
The source.
No way.
Mint the tree!
It calls to me.
I must go to it.
Goodbye, Minto.
We will meet again after I return.
No!
They said don't go to the tree!
They said...
Yeah, everybody 07.
We will miss you random person.
Well, thank you so much for the 20 gift today.
Thank you.
Random citizen.
Um, let's see.
We can...
Wake maker.
An arm mounted jets for underwater maneuvering.
Risk of shoulder strain.
Okay, oh, I do need a battery though, don't I?
For, um...
For my...
Uh...
My scanner.
Reload Load Nice Okay And then I guess I can't even make
this Fully functional fabricator What
else?
I thought we got like a repair thing too Okay Okay Let's
grab some food Little fish Little fish little fish the way
they tremble it's so sad um edible fish you guys are you
guys edible edible edible fish oh you're so fast please let
me eat you ow ow ow ow
oh ow
emotional support slug Well, we do need water anyways, but I
was trying to find some fish.
That's fine.
We'll just make the water real quick.
Water?
I think I'm out of water.
No, that's a big old lie.
All right, give me some fish.
There we go, there we go.
Yeah.
Oh!
Cooked harvest.
moon.
I didn't have that guy before.
Oh!
Three moon temaki!
Today I learned that ghosts can swim.
It only took two years.
How could I not swim when my hands go like this perfectly?
Naturally.
How do I fix my fabricator, guys?
How do we fix it?
Is it by building the base?
You need to make a base.
You need to build a new one.
Build a new base, new fabricator.
Well, okay.
Here's my problem.
With building the base.
Oh!
A room!
Valid support surface.
So like this.
Build area obstructed.
Wait, is this all titanium?
No, this is what I need the titanium.
Oh, underwater.
Duh, I knew that.
What do you mean the game where you have to dive in the
water?
You have to build in the water.
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean by the subnautica, not overnautica?
What?
Why?
That's craziness.
Here, let's build it like right here.
All right, nice.
Okay, we'll need more titanium, but also...
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
A hatch to get in.
Nice.
and uh
cord okay we're gonna make this real nice
yeah we can stack it yeah we need the power we need the
power that's right uh exterior quartz we need some quartz
well we also need titanium so let's grab that grab you and
some quartz we'll find somewhere.
Quartz, quartz, quartz.
Eat me down here.
Oxygen.
I got it, I got it.
I got the oxygen.
Chill out.
Is this, that looks like titanium.
Nope, that's copper.
Let's still take it.
More titanium.
I'm about to prove nothing to lose.
Far away.
Ricochet, you take your way.
You shoot me down, but I get up.
I'm titanium.
Oh, what else did I need?
Oh, quartz.
I have so much.
I should have just brought it here.
Okay.
I'm titanium!
Solar panel?
Okay.
Fish are super cute, but the cutest one is the catch in the
corner.
She's a catch, alright.
Oh, here we go.
Can I get it now?
Welcome aboard.
Oxygen production offline.
Wait, but I have my solar power!
Wait!
You're supposed to be active!
Oh,
I didn't build it.
Oops.
What, actually...
Oh, what?
Power connected.
All systems online.
Welcome aboard.
Ah.
What we'll do is I'll do this.
We'll build another room.
Oh, I need more titanium.
But we'll build it like this and then we can stack it, you
know?
Okay, let's go get some titanium.
Somewhere on the floor.
Titanium, what are you?
I'm looking for you on the ocean floor.
I know you're around.
There you are.
Yeah, I'm gonna float.
I kind of want to build it to the surface so that like...
I can see it.
Yeah, I did see that you can like kind of like extend the
room a little bit.
Oh.
The Kabo- Oh, oh no!
I was off!
Wait.
Sick bars.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
it looks it's good like that it is it's perfect really you
think so all right time to start building stuff for real
fabricator bada bing bada boom yeah oh i need more do i need
more do i need the Oh, I need more energy.
Or is it because it's night time?
Power's going to be low at night.
Okay, okay.
Let's start, um...
Getting some stuff over.
I do want to, like, make lockers and everything.
So we can have more storage.
Maybe the metal salvage and things like that would be what
we need.
need for it.
But if I do build another... Oh, did it say I need quartz?
Dang it.
That's okay.
Welcome aboard.
Oh, my oxygen is still going down.
Must construct additional pylons.
Oh, geez.
Made the tree beautiful join us.
No!
Good in the ocean matches the vibe.
So true, so true.
Don't go into the light.
I mean, the tree does look pretty cool, though.
You think it's one of those things where if you go over,
there's like a crazy Leviathan?
Quartz.
Did I have more quartz at home?
We have quartz at home.
I can't remember.
I respect your dedication to the grind, sick and still
putting on a show for us.
Thank you for always being able to brighten a day even when
you're down.
I'm all good.
I'm just a little nasally.
The most inconvenient part is I can't wear my IEMs.
I have to wear my headphones.
So it's kind of annoying.
I'll have to like disinfect them too, I think afterwards.
Yuck.
All right, let's put this away for now.
Take this copper.
I mean quartz, not copper.
Oh!
The sun is coming up!
What's that over there?
Those are mountains, not clouds.
But also, don't they kind of look like like cactus in the
desert?
Half of your back, I'm off to my honeymoon.
Where are you going?
Or is this an invite?
Are we allowed?
Solar panels make more power close to the surface.
Oh, do they now?
Okay, well, what I wanted to do anyway was I wanted to...
Power connected.
All systems online.
Yippee!
I wanted to make another room on top of this guy, right?
And...
We could put a solar panel up on top of there.
Wait, are these connected?
These are connected, right?
Welcome aboard.
Oh.
Do I need to make a hatch?
Grow room.
I'll have to place a ladder.
They connect via ladder.
Which we did unlock.
The interior.
Interior crocodile alligator.
Oh, there it is.
Ah, here we go.
Let me go get some more.
There we go.
Thank you.
I'll take that.
I'll take that too.
Wait, I'm like, I'm on the prize.
I need more.
I need titanium.
I drive a Chevrolet movie theater.
You know, you know it.
Wait, don't get sucked in.
Don't get sucked.
Nice!
No!
Oh, geez.
Okay, I'll be back.
I only got two.
Salvage the metal.
Oh, wait, is that what it's for?
The metal scrap is for the titanium.
Wait, I thought it was like, I was saving it.
because i thought it was for uh like creating something wait
oh my god it turns into multiple oh it's throwing it around
okay we'll collect it after holy it's just it's just
throwing it everywhere okay awesome then let's do this
perfect Pick up, pick up.
I'm not littering, it's my own home.
And now if I, now can I move this?
Enter move mode.
Move you up here.
Oh, oh.
Did I do it?
I can't, okay.
Wait, okay.
Okay, I think I did.
it okay lockers for storage yes yes yes yes that's what I
wanted to do floor locker make that we'll put them like kind
of close to the entrance yeah
okay and then it got all quiet all of a sudden wait why is
it why is it why can't I put it right next to him there we
go okay Alright!
Nice!
Okay, very good, very good.
Oh, there has to be- we have to be able to create something
that can recharge that, no?
Recharge the batteries?
Nice, nice, okay.
Oh, yeah.
And take back my- oh, metal salvage?
And my water, okay.
The battery charger.
I think I did get that didn't I?
And the grease!
What's the grease do?
Oh Oh, okay, nothing apparently We have so much titanium.
It's awesome Wow I want a window and stuff.
Yeah, we're gonna make it look so nice in here Oh yeah, oh
yeah, oh yeah, wait.
Um, let's get some, let's make some windows!
Ooh!
Oh, it's gonna be so...
Oh.
Wait, I thought I had a glass.
Did I use it already?
Did I use my glass?
Never played any of these games.
They feel real chill.
They are...
Until they aren't.
Oh, look at that!
Our window.
Wait, I just made that for no reason, but that's fine.
We can make another window up here.
That is a very good way to describe it.
I think so.
I think so, right?
Oh, I didn't.
It's, like, not even.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, never mind.
We'll think of it.
Oh, okay, there we go.
It's not finished.
Now it is.
Oh, wait.
That's kind of like a hack, though.
You just create the window and then never complete it.
And then it's always just a window.
Mmm!
You can change the window size.
Guys?
No way.
Oh,
I gotta go get more quartz though, actually.
That's crazy!
I don't think, I think these are empty.
Yeah.
Where can I find some more quartz?
Maybe in here?
I think I went down here already before though.
Grab the copper.
Soon, soon we should be...
Wait, I think this is the flashlight!
Yes!
Oh my gosh, finally!
Okay, okay, we just need one more and we should be able
to...
Okay.
Very nice.
Can I have some oxygen plays?
And...
Thank you!
Yeah!
Okay, quartz.
We fill this deep ocean with wine!
Quartz, quartz, quartz, quartz.
If I were a quartz, I would be hanging out in a nice little
area.
Is it scrap?
Yes.
Hmm.
What are you?
Gordy?
I'll take you.
Oh, nice!
Courts!
Okay.
Courts, courts!
We got two courts!
Which means we can make...
Okay, we need more courts.
These games are so like...
They're very chill in the beginning too.
Which makes them...
Like, easy to play, you know?
I don't need any more titanium.
I do need some fish to eat, though.
What is this?
Well, titanium, big.
Seek caloric intake.
Okay.
Deceptively welcoming.
That's a good way to put it, too, though.
Honestly.
It is very deceptively welcoming.
Like, oh yeah, this is so chill.
Oh yeah, I'm just collecting quartz and titaniums and having
a good time.
And then, they're like, oh, but you must go deeper for other
things.
And that's when it starts getting a little scary.
Then you remember we aren't fish.
Even if we were fish, though.
Let's see, all right.
Welcome aboard.
I find it funny how Mint waits until the last minute to eat
and drink.
Personally I cannot stand not being topped off as soon as...
Ah look.
It's just food is not on the top of my brain right now.
Though I do need to collect some more fish for sure.
But right now my brain is thinking...
My brain is thinking...
Build.
I'm mining and I'm crafting, okay?
I think that should be enough.
75 glass!
How do I have 0.75 glass?
Excuse me?
I only have one or none.
I never eat till it tells me.
You're just like me then.
She doesn't eat till she gets the shakes.
Okay, but that's kind of how I am.
right now.
Anybody want to offer something tasty for me to eat?
I would be very appreciative.
Glask.
What else can we make?
We can make Biolab.
Mild Acid.
Modifies your... Okay, yeah, that's right.
Processor.
Complex biochemical and manufacturing takes over time.
Mild Acid and Copper Wire.
Don't we have the mild acid?
Okay, if we get a lot of Copper wire?
We can make a couple things.
Don't really need the processor or biolab right now.
But...
Whoops.
Uh...
We do need...
Scanner station?
Okay, it's resources.
Thanks for the hot dog!
Wait, Minecraft now noise.
Wait, that's not it.
That's better.
I'll paraphrase the great Ian Malcolm.
Oh, yeah.
That's how it always starts.
Then later they're swimming and screaming.
Is that how it goes?
So Nautica starts as underwater, underworld Minecraft.
adventure mode then it's deep sea justified the less is a
phobia simulator yeah actually thanks for the other hot dog
we really got a hook mint up with a sea caloric and take
voice that place in her head it's called my tummy tummy
rumbling is that not good enough let's see the battery
terminal we'll do it right here Very good.
And then what else can we build?
Bio bed.
I feel like we're right next to our current bio bed, so we
really don't need to make that.
Mission critical locates resources, wrecks, and anomalies.
With an expanded range.
High power draw.
Oh, interesting.
Okay, so it's scanning.
Okay.
How about that beacon we don't really need?
Portable locker.
Oh, our furniture!
Lost River poster.
That's freaky.
What the heck is that?
Scanner is useful.
Okay.
What else can we build?
Reaper Leviathan!
Oh, he's huge.
Wait.
Can I build him outside?
Oh, must be placed inside the base.
Dang it.
Oh, it's a below zero fossil.
Oh, okay, okay.
I can't...
Genoetic Advisor has transmitted an alert.
Return to the life pod at your convenience.
He's too big.
He's too big!
It's literally just his model.
He's guarding my house.
Yeah, it gives the front door jump scare.
Honestly, I feel like I'm going to forget I placed him here.
Oh, yeah, I could make the room much bigger.
That's true.
I could just expand.
Maybe I could put him up here.
Whoa!
It's so beautiful.
Did I get over there?
Did I get that?
This game is actually addicting, though.
fun to play these to play this game fun until it's so scary
oh it's the these nasties wait four there we go oh it's a
habitat builder whatever I'll scan it anyway anything here
oh what's down here or fart sponges Oxygen.
I really need to find a way to get silver.
Oh.
I'm dying.
What's over here?
Let's go explore.
Oxygen.
Oh, this is the arm thing.
The wake maker.
Wait, I can go make that now, can't I?
Or did I need it?
I don't think I needed it.
Yeah, I don't need another one We can just make it.
Let's go do that Maybe that will be
Life pod this way Leisha way.
Oh, I need silver for it.
Ah But I thought that I would if I got it then I would be
able to mine the silver.
That's where like my biggest This is where we're kind of
stuck a bit.
Because I can't mine the silver.
So I'm a bit stuck.
Of like how to.
Get that.
Love that the scanner shows if you have it already.
Yeah, it's pretty helpful.
Like I think the fact that like the things.
Oh boy, it scared me.
The...
Oh, shoot.
Um...
Silver's hard to find.
Okay.
They did want me to try and die, so...
We will go to a scary, spooky place.
And, uh, try that.
How exciting.
Need to dive deeper.
Yeah, but I wish...
I could have a better air tank to dive deeper.
It's a little frustrating.
Fiber mesh and grease.
Wiring kit.
Which we need silver as well.
Wait.
Let me start taking this stuff actually over to my other
base.
Oh!
And let's eat.
There are air pockets.
true.
Actually, I'm gonna...
There we go.
Actually, let's try and make this more clean.
Okay.
We'll make this a little easier.
Oh, there's my mild acid.
I knew I had some.
If you had another solar panel, the power will stay on at
night.
Let's do it.
Will it still work now?
If I even construct it at this very moment?
Will it still work?
Seek fresh water intake.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I have to be under the water.
But it keeps bringing me to the surface of the water.
Oh, I need quartz!
Oops.
Hmm.
Drink water.
Hi, Sippy.
My quartz was in this guy.
Oh, wait, hold on.
That's what I was doing.
I was like, what did I go in here for?
To put my stuff away in the locker.
Thank you.
Oh, cancel.
open uh
okay good all right gamer sippy everybody hydrate let's grab
this guy too for some snackage oh yeah the elicious my
favorite whatever this guy is okay i think it was like what
like two and a half quarts or something stupid okay yes
oxygen I'm fine, we're fine.
Okay.
Oh!
Yippee!
Nope, come here.
Come here, you.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Just grab him.
Yeah, grab him and grab that guy too.
We're gonna have a little buffet real quick.
We're gonna eat and we're gonna drink the night away, baby.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Wait, the coral even gives me that.
I didn't realize.
Snacks everywhere.
You hungry, buddy?
Well, do I have the feast for you?
Wait, the oily salad!
Yahoo!
Oily salad!
My favorite.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
It's from Delivery Dumpcious.
Oh, that was not a good It sounded like we ate the salad,
box, and all.
But like...
Oh, oh.
That's how you do it, I guess.
That's what that means, right?
It biodegrades in your stomach, too.
That was the crunchiest, crunchest.
What are you?
Can I take you?
No.
You're just a crab.
With no purpose.
What is that?
Copper.
He looks cute.
Yeah, he does.
That's why I wanted him.
Welcome aboard.
Thank you.
Uh...
More water.
That should be good, probably.
Okay.
Very good.
Let's store some more stuff.
I'm just gonna store everything because we're going with the
intent of dying.
But I also do want to wait until...
morning.
Quab is friend.
Indeed.
If it's super oily, maybe you need the extra fiber to help
absorb it?
I guess so.
Hydration check, IRL, I-Buzz!
Are you guys nice and...
You need to stay hydrated.
It's good for you.
If I'm not hydrated, my ectoplasm dries up.
I need agua.
Agua.
Oh wait.
Actually, we can take...
We can take one of these.
Okay.
We're going... I don't know how much of our inventory we
lose.
Like if it's the stuff in our...
Your advisor has transmitted an alert.
Return to the life port at your convenience.
At my convenience, you say, okay?
So, not yet.
It's not convenient for me.
Silver?
So far?
Oxygen efficiency decreased.
Guys, I think we're gonna die.
Oxygen.
No one!
No, the air bladder I couldn't use.
mine thank you have fun with hitman try the northern base
you explored earlier the caves have lots oh thank you I'll
try that then let's go that way thank you yeah I inhaled the
bladder instead maybe like a fool
that was close I started I started seeing in dog vision.
My world was going black and white.
I was about to be a film noir.
Handling hydration right now.
Making Gam-Maita!
Good choice.
Gam-Maita is so delicious.
That stuff is so yummy.
Gam-Maita.
These guys suck though.
Leave me alone.
Leave me alone, Neal.
I think I got away from him.
Oh, that's my body.
That scared me.
Minky versus character.
Who will win the breath hold context?
I... I don't need to breathe!
I do it so that you guys feel comfortable.
My nose is starting to get...
Wheelie, wheelie stuffed again.
We've been to that one, right?
Wait, what is that?
No, we haven't.
What is this?
Caution.
You have entered a viral bloom.
All other microbial life in the seawater is dead.
The ocean is blighted.
Gather scans and return with appropriate treatment
equipment.
Okay.
I don't know what the heck that was.
Oh, we're just not going to mess with that.
At the moment.
All right.
Caves in here.
Oh, yeah, there was this guy's, like, death thing that we
didn't go to.
What are these?
They're kind of funny.
Oh, geez.
Jellies.
I'm going up.
All right.
All right, down here maybe.
If we die, we die, everybody.
We die with pride.
If we die.
What's that?
Wait, I can't even pick it up, though.
Titanium.
I'm bulletproof.
Where am I at?
Oh, I'm past it, actually.
Fire away.
Take a snack.
In my pack.
Fire away.
Oh, oh, shoot.
Go up.
Okay.
And back down.
Hmm.
I don't even see any caves around here.
Can I go in here now?
Where was this guy's thing?
Oh, we can!
Wait.
Oh, no.
This is where I went into before.
Wait a second.
Where was this guy?
Ah, that's a life pod.
Where's this guy's death thing?
Oh, he's over here.
I completely missed him.
My bad.
Sorry, buddy.
Uh...
Ah!
Seal the focus.
Keep the fire away from the lab.
Oh.
I've cracked it.
Oh, we didn't...
Okay.
We will never find his Xbox.
I bet it has Uno on it, if we do find it.
Okay, so we got that, but, um, let's go...
Is this silver?
I can't get it, though!
Wait, no, this looks like quartz.
Yeah, that's a big thing of quartz.
Oh, this is... this is food.
Yeah.
Grab that.
That's the... that's the yummy sap.
This looks like silver!
No, it's quartz!
I can't tell the difference.
Okay, let's keep going down.
This titanium.
More titanium.
We gotta go further.
Silver is pyramid.
Titanium.
Oops, I'll cork.
Should we head towards the tree?
Well, Leviathan will be out towards this way, I wonder.
I already see something.
What is that?
The tree.
The tree, the tree.
Oh, did I just pass?
Wait, what is this?
Subnautica 2 is actively being developed while...
I was reading!
I was a mid-text!
It did say explore at your own risk.
We didn't die, though.
Actually, let's go back.
Maybe he can teleport me back home.
I'll eat first.
Where's the wall?
Show me the wall.
Show me the gamer wall.
Early access preview area.
Building disabled.
The fact that the music came up was so scary.
Where's he at?
Micmac, thanks for the gifting!
Yee!
Oh my god!
You have experienced conditions incompatible with life.
Your brain state has been restored to a new body.
Some colonists prefer to return to the Axton site to
retrieve lost items and verify their last print exited
cleanly.
he launched a little baby at me should have scanned it the
squad pulled up to say hi I only had a couple things it's
all one of them was like a fish it was like a fish and some
quartz or something I think we're all right
Wander.
K.
Wander Wangmo.
A young Abel Spacer.
Partial voice data retrieved.
Mirror breach got me.
Should have brought flares.
Mirror breach.
Do you remember when she stole that fried dough from her
brother and offered it to you?
Right in front of him.
An egregious act of sisterhood.
Signal location uploaded to PDA.
Be cautious.
Seawater viral load increases sharply out west of the life
pod.
I've noticed something about me recently.
That kind of reminded me of this, what it wrote.
And that, like...
It's so bad, and I noticed it, and I was just like, oh my
gosh, wait, I probably seem so rude when I do this.
But, like...
Um...
Like, someone will, like, give me something or something,
and then I'll be like oh this person also likes the same
thing as me let me give them the thing or like for example
like we went to an idol live and we were pulling gotcha and
um Vicky and Phoebe they both pulled my Oshi and I was like
oh thank you but it was two of the same thing right and then
my friend was also there and she has the same Oshi is me as
well.
And I was like, here, you can have the other extra?
And then I was like, wait a second, but... But that's like
my friend.
You know, I was like, that's my friend.
That's not, that's not Vicky or Phoebe's friend.
And then I felt really bad because I was just like, oh,
maybe, maybe they, they, you know, were just kind of like,
oh, Minto gave away the thing that we just gave to her.
But it was really just that I didn't need to.
And so I wanted to give my friend one as well.
So I felt bad.
But I do that sometimes as well.
I'll be like, oh, I have multiple.
Or I'll be like, oh, I have multiple of this or something.
And,
but I feel bad because it's like, oh, somebody's giving me
something.
And then I immediately, I'm just like, to another person
like, Oh, do you want this?
Because...
I end up feeling bad.
I think especially if Vicky and Phoebe would understand you
just being generous.
Of course, obviously, like, I appreciate them giving me the
thing.
And I even asked my friend first, I was like, did you get
one?
And they were like, no.
I was like, oh, here you go.
I got the extra.
Minto's a dirty re-gifter.
AHAA!
I was like, you know, it's one thing if it's like, you know,
my own thing that I give to somebody, but I was like, maybe
I should, maybe I should be like a little more cautious
about that.
If, you know, if somebody, if somebody gives me something, I
shouldn't just immediately offer it to somebody else.
Oopsie.
I think making sure people get merch of the Roshis is good.
important people will understand i hope that's the case i
mean obviously when i pulled something of vicky's oshi i
immediately gave it to her too so i think i think for uh for
idols and things like that you know when it's like a gotcha
and people have different oshi then maybe people understand
but i don't think i mean i have i probably i have good
intentions I just don't want it to come off the wrong way
and it's like they gave me something and then I immediately
am handing it off to somebody else I
remember another time and I wait what was it someone gifted
me something and I immediately was just like oh if you like
it here you go to somebody else
But I should be, I should be, he gave a duplicate, not the
only one you had.
Oopsie.
I'll be, so then this is like, you remember the, that she
took the doll from her brother and offered it to you?
That's how I felt.
I was like, oh no.
Oh no.
Yeah.
But yeah.
Anyway.
What was I doing?
Oh, I died.
That's right.
I didn't see any silver.
That way.
Let's try to go to camp one, maybe.
Camp one, camp one.
Camp rock!
Can't rock!
Why do these fish sound so big when they're not even that
big?
Uh-oh, sorry, I missed the super chat.
It's so late.
Late night, Minto, what is your wisdom of the night?
Um...
Think before you act.
What's going on down here?
I'll take this guy.
Oh, another...
Another portable locker.
Wait, I'll take that?
Oh, what is that?
I just took something?
Wait, where's my scanner?
Scanning everything?
Open this?
More block?
Crab tower?
Two spare tanks.
My reprint site is Habitat.
I'm exhausted today.
What if you just reprinted yourself when you were tired?
Maybe he's never out of his sleep.
Kind of crazy.
I'm checking out the big coral tower.
There's a mass trapped inside.
The scanner's not sure if it's coral polyp or crab tissue.
Crab tissue.
The genetics are so weird.
We know the Protea virus infects everything on this planet.
And we know the coral crabs wear these domes as hats.
Oh yeah, we saw that guy.
Is it possible the virus swapped their genes around?
Follow that cable?
Decided it was a crab.
Like if you live next to something on Proteus, you become
related to it.
Where's the cave?
Oh, this one?
I was trying to follow that one cable before earlier, wasn't
I?
What are you?
Courts?
Yeah.
Ew!
Oh.
Suck.
Wait.
Health pack.
Why do I need that for?
Um, maybe that was a bad idea.
Surely there's a thing that produces oxygen down here?
Surely?
Wait.
Oh, thank goodness!
Wait, what is this?
A sponge.
I passed silver?
I did?
Wait.
Oh, sorry.
Philosophically, reprints are new people, right?
Imagine if they reprinted a clone while you were still
alive.
That's a...
That's that Mickey...
Mickey...
Mickey 13?
I passed silver.
Oh, here?
Oh, my God!
We got silver.
Silver ingot.
It feels so good.
Thank you, everybody.
Oh wait, here more!
And here!
Yes!
Keep looking, I am, I am, I am!
Big copper.
Oh, there's some more, I think?
Where are those?
Brought copper.
I didn't have...
Cabbage shoot route.
What's this?
Does this thing scare me?
Does this thing...
hate me?
Does this thing eat me?
Wait, let's go back.
Oh shoot.
Oxygen.
No, I'm not full yet.
Yeah, I have to make it back home.
I feel like I should just go back.
We'll come back here.
to go back home.
You know?
We know where this is.
This was pretty...
This was a pretty easy find.
Yeah, play it safe with new resources.
Exactly.
Where is home?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Yes.
My base!
Wow, it was actually so close.
It was actually so close.
Oh my goodness.
Leviathan.
I think also I need to build a node guy here.
I probably should.
Hmm.
No terminal.
Only glass.
Leviathan.
Wait a second.
Something is different about you, Mito.
Something dimensional.
Whatever could you mean.
What could you mean?
What do you mean?
Whatever?
What could you mean?
New perfume?
Do you smell?
Smell, smell, smell, smell Smell, smell, smell, smell Smell,
smell?
Do I smell?
Am I smelly?
I still don't see it, could you spin again?
Oh, I'm about to die of thirst.
Let me do that first.
I'm about to die of thirst, everybody.
And I'm hungry.
Ish.
The game was not paused.
Good to know.
Noah Terminal.
Oh, can...
Really?
Obstructed?
How?
Even here?
why can't I make one on the wall like the other guy you know
hey you minko so stanko mink but no I literally actually
it's I'll shower after ghost don't smell I smell minty
fresh.
What were we doing?
We're building stuff, guys.
Ignore, ignore.
Ignore.
Ignore what they want you to...
Our air tank!
Huge!
A wiring kit.
Let's make that.
Other wiring kit.
Those eyes say she's taking...
She's taking D-O-T.
What is that?
Dot.
What's that?
What are you saying?
Um, wakemaker!
The wakemaker is a marine adaptation of the space maker.
Oh, damage over time.
No, I'm not.
should be careful to rest their wrist, elbows, and shoulders
during prolonged use.
Alan Wake?
Did you guys see that there's an Alan Wake in Phasmophobia
now?
Like, rather, there is Alan Wake DLC, question mark?
Or an event?
Alan Wake event?
In... in... in... in... Phasmophobia.
Yeah, really?
I kind of want to play it.
I kind of want to play it, though.
Two of my friends just ditched me to go play it.
You should go play it, too.
Yeah, you go to the Odeer Cafe and everything.
I didn't know they were still updating Fasmo.
A lot, actually.
To...
Um...
The dismay of not...
Some people are not fans of the newest update.
I'll tell you that.
Hehehe.
Look at that.
My snack is flying by.
What the?
My snack is in my house!
System chip.
Self-contained system on...
Oh, no, no, no.
Free food?
It's delivery!
Wow.
Maybe I should start using DoorDash.
It's kind of convenient.
Wait, so how do I do this?
Equip it.
Oh, let's put our silver away.
Huh.
How do I use it?
Whoa!
Toggle lights.
Oh.
Did they help me go faster or...
Oh, yeah, and I have so much air.
The world is different now, everybody.
No, no, thank you so much for the time gifted.
Thank you.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I was not paying attention.
These are awesome.
can get this.
Yeah.
What's over here?
I'm hearing a big, big, big noise.
What's this?
Oh, down here.
Oh, this is where I first found the silver.
No.
Yeah, this one.
What do I need for it?
So curious.
Did I scan everything in here?
Because I definitely don't know.
Oh, yes I did.
This is when I think I first remembered that I needed to
start scanning things.
Rapid!
Thank you so much, motherfucker!
Good day!
So what is this game to you?
What do you do?
Oh, what is this game about?
Um...
You pick up salt.
Man.
You go around.
There's all sorts of things to do.
Oh.
Aw, I don't like the way they shake.
It makes me sad.
What's this?
Quartz.
But it's still in...
The Noetic Advisor has transmitted an alert.
Return to the life port at your convenience.
At my convenience, so not right now.
I'm busy.
30 seconds.
What does that mean?
What do you mean 30 seconds?
Of air?
Don't just start counting down!
Okay, of air, okay.
Good to know.
Otherwise, that was terrifying.
It's just a terrifying remark.
Yeah, until what?
This guy's like dangerous.
Titanium.
Everything is titanium.
I think we're gonna hit the wall again.
Context, please, computer.
Right.
More corpse.
I'm just going around at the moment.
Grab a little snack on the way.
What's that right there?
It's shining.
It's piquing my interest.
Oh, I didn't realize we were so low.
What is this?
Wait, is this where the crab is?
Perhaps?
Wait, I think that's a crab, no?
It looks kind of dead.
Are you okay?
Wake up.
Wait, there's all crabs.
These are all crabs.
What was that?
Titanium, of course it is.
This is a crab.
Wake up?
I'm in the crab!
Hold on, hold on!
Ugh!
Hmm.
Why are they- is it because of the virus?
Isn't that what they were talking about before?
What's going on?
over here.
This game is so fun and terrifying to explore.
New creature!
That's a life preserver!
What are you?
Sonic ring.
Here we go.
50 points.
Ah, why?
Jelly ring.
Wait, hold on.
I'm trying to Scan this guy.
Jelly ring.
Oh,
okay, okay.
Too hot.
Too spicy.
Let's go home.
Wait, I can't go home through here.
Too spicy?
Makes a funny noise if you bump into it.
Is this gonna kill me?
Spicy water.
Oh, wait.
Am I getting hurt?
No.
Bong, bong.
Oh, more crab.
More dead crab.
30 seconds.
She's so... She reminds me of the...
What's it called?
The thing in MGS5.
The iDroid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
30 seconds.
This guy is going to need to recharge soon.
Can I even go down here?
Ugh, fine.
You do not want to cross that cliff.
What happens?
What will I lose?
Oh, whatever.
East is danger?
Well, I already saw that one guy.
What else could there be?
It's fine.
I got my lights on.
Here, I'll even go up a little.
Uh-huh.
Onward.
Eastward.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot.
Yeah!
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I think I'm gonna die.
No, I'm gonna die to oxygen!
Of all things!
Print lost to suffocation.
Woof!
Yikes!
Ruby.
T, Ruby and R, lead pilot.
Partial voice data retrieved.
Ooh!
Uh-oh.
Do you remember the flight to the Zika?
Before you were scanned into storage, Ruby kept maneuvering
the shuttle wildly, and then apologizing to the passengers.
i don't know how you felt about it personally i was charmed
she finds her work intoxicating and that's what life is all
about loving what you do signal location uploaded to your
pdr why can't we have gills why why why why why why well
guys i think that's where we'll end it today though do you
want to enjoy the sunset with me.
We have a snack.
I'll feed you.
Look at this.
Oh, hold on.
I can grab them.
Grab and I'll get us some drinks too.
I'll get us some drinks too.
Just give me a second.
Pick up some salvage.
Oh, wait.
Don't go in there.
Here we go.
Some drinks.
Why did these guys and make home underneath my underneath my
base.
They're too cute.
Drinks and snacks.
Yeah, for the sunset.
Welcome aboard.
Thank you.
I will not feed you the oily salad.
You only get the best cooked harvest moon.
One for me and one for you.
One for me.
One for you.
Goop.
Nice.
It is the sunset, right?
Not the sun wrongers?
The sun's going down?
One for boo.
Climb, climb, climb, climb, climb.
Climb, climb, climb.
Climb, climb.
Climb.
Climb, climb, climb.
Why am I so bad at this?
Climb!
There we go.
And now we watch the sun set?
Question mark?
Such skill.
It's hard to climb in flippers.
You are so right!
It's not me!
I'm a fan of Eve!
Thank you so much for the help!
Thank you!
Thanks for the underwater adventure in 3D, Minto.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow.
Wow, I want to know more about those guys.
This was a lot of fun.
It felt just like Old Subnautica, but...
Not.
It's just something a little different.
A little, little, little, little.
little different about it.
Yeah.
The flying goldfish.
Darko, thank you so much for the peek.
Thank you!
Thank you for the chill stream.
It was fun to hang out with you and to see and experience
your breathtaking appearance in 3D.
Oh, thank you.
Your extra dimension of cuteness makes our brains go oxygen.
As you seek caloric intake, may your food be digestible and
delicious.
Thank you!
Let's uh...
Let's look into the sunset together.
It's beautiful.
Why is it so cloudy?
I can't see anything.
Thank you, Minky, for the stream.
I wish you the best.
I hope you can stay healthy soon.
And maybe a possible return to the sea.
Otamito!
Thank you, Mobius!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, here it is.
This is prettier.
A little bit.
More 3D streams in the future, please?
I would like to, I would like to.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm still learning about it, so it takes me a little longer.
But...
Whoa.
Now they didn't nail the lighting, right?
Wow.
Very pretty view.
And a sunset too, I guess.
Stop!
Whoa!
And also, I'm not even in play, I'm not even playing in like
the ultra.
I'm playing in just high.
So not even like ultra settings or anything.
Don't stare directly into the sun!
Oh, whoops.
Everything
is dots!
Thank you, everybody!
Otsubita!
It's... it's a...
It's a...
Thank
you.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
this sunset is nice but i can't take my eyes off the thing
in the bottom right who fills my life with light every day
fill your dark soul with a light make me cute wait i can
also do other hold on
wait oh boy boy boy boy
peace out peace bye bye